foule immense qui envahit le tarmac pour
tenter de fuir par tous les moyens
l'afghanistan
kaboul va-t-il ou 2021
le canada a mis fin à son opération
d'évacuation dans le chaos le plus total
les militaires canadiens quittent
l'afghanistan après avoir extirpé point
1700 personnes de cet enfer mais la
mission se termine avec un goût amer
évidemment c'est frustrant je trouve ça
excitant car beaucoup d'afghans en
danger de mort ont été laissées derrière
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant deux mois que
l'afghanistan est entièrement aux mains
des talibans
deux mois de clandestinité de stress et
de terreur pour des milliers dans ses
interprètes et employés locaux de
l'armée canadienne et leur entourage
coincé en afghanistan nous en avons
retracé une demi-douzaine ils vivent
tous aujourd'hui cacher et dans la peur
d'être découvert leur visage a été
masquée pour protéger leur identité
tareen a travaillé deux ans comme
interprète pour les forces canadiennes
employés entre autres par l'équipe
provinciale de reconstruction
mais cet été il a dû fuir kandar pour se
réfugier à kaboul
[Musique]
les talibans ont détruit sa maison et
menacer ses voisins
non
c'est aussi à kaboul que se cache
matiullah terrorisé
il a travaillé trois ans avec les
canadiens comme pharmacien et technicien
médical à l'hôpital militaire de
kandahar
avec eux il a contribué à sauver des
vies
et le danger est encore plus élevé à
kandahar où david est resté
ses années de service auprès des forces
spéciales canadiennes ne lui procure
aucune protection bien au contraire
pour le séchage
c'est quand je suis fâché avec qu'est-ce
qui se passe
cela fait déjà plusieurs années que le
réserviste d'événements a raccroché son
uniforme il a été l'un des derniers
canadiens déployés à kandahar en 2011
mais l'afghanistan ne l'a jamais
vraiment quitté j'ai jamais vraiment
parti complètement de l'afghanistan
parce que j'étais j'avais toujours un
lien avec mon interprète des vides est
aujourd'hui dégoûté en constatant le
manque d'empressement du canada a sauvé
six ans et interprète afghan - chef y
allait de soldats canadiens nés depuis
joue en juillet puis la réponse
gouvernement canadien j'ai pas cette
fille stella sa partie avec d'autres
anciens combattants canadiens il a
dressé une liste de dix mille personnes
à sauver d'urgence une liste transmise à
immigration canada mais depuis ils
déplorent le peu de résultats sur cette
nuit là
nous avons seulement 8 % de ces noms là
qui sont arrivés ici au canada
clairement c'est un échec
ce n'est qu'en juillet dernier plus de
dix ans après avoir quitté kandar que le
canada a mis en place un plan pour
protéger ses ancien interprète un
programme créé en urgence sous la
pression des anciens combattants
indignées parmi eux le major général
denis thompson qui commandait qu'en 2008
2009 le détachement canadiens en
afghanistan
je ne sais pas si je suis fâché ou déçu
mais je suis frustré c'est vrai ces gens
ils méritent notre attention
constatant l'inaction d'ottawa les
anciens combattants ont mis sur pied une
ong pour aider eux mêmes les afghans
menacent et le tout géré à distance avec
très peu de moyens
c'est quand même un devoir moral c'est
pas le moment de laisser tomber nos
camarades dans
l'application d'ottawa se limite au
traitement par immigration canada des
dossiers de ceux qui ont réussi à
quitter pays par eux mêmes
une lourdeur administrative
dénoncé de tous côtés
ça sent qu'il n'y a aucune urgence ça
sent qu'il
ait
sollicité pour une entrevue le ministre
canadien de l'immigration a refusé de
répondre à nos questions et il faut
trouver un autre solution pour
évacuer ce monde là comme beaucoup
d'anciens combattants le général
thompson souhaite un sérieux coup de
barre de tahoua dans ce dossier mais il
faut plus d'actions sur le terrain
physiquement pour hull pour que ce monde
pour quitter le pays d'afghanistan un
changement d'attitude qui doit venir de
tout en haut de la hiérarchie les
interprètes afghans l'ont bien compris
mais c'est surtout
la vie harkin engel betting
mais pour bon nombre d'afghans la
confiance est rompue l'espoir a disparu
c'est ainsi en écosse qu'abdul l'ancien
interprète de d'événements au a
finalement trouvé refuge après avoir
compris la mort dans l'âme qu'il ne
pouvait plus compter sur le canada
[Musique]